[Music]
[Applause]
Andrew Brandt former Packer executive
host of business of sports podcast and a
columnist and had a recent column where
he talked about could we see the Saudi
Investment Group by a team in the NFL
Andrew joins us on that topic let me
start there we had commissioner silver
on yesterday talking about could the
Saudis buy a team in the NBA Michael
Jordan I think his team is up for sale
or he's talked about that uh and they
and the commissioner said you have to
have a a singular person you can't have
a group by an NBA team
could you walk us through the process if
the Saudis say we're going to spend 10
billion dollars we want to buy this
football team the Jacksonville Jaguars
yeah good to be with you Dan that's
probably not going to happen anytime
soon the NFL like the NBA requires sort
of a person I've been NFL meetings for
10 years and they want that person
representing the team and that has to
have 30 percent of these total values my
point is in talking and writing about
this over the last week is that
franchise values are skyrocketing as we
know it's extraordinary what the numbers
are in the NFL four years ago the
Panthers 2.2 billion last year the
Broncos 4 billion and now we got the
commanders at 6.05 billion at some point
the NFL and the NBA are gonna have to
adjust their rules about ownership and
taking institutional money now
institutional money could meet private
equity which is allowed in these leagues
except for the NFL but now we talk about
the Saudis what just happened in Golf
shows the unlimited resources that they
have Dan you've seen this I mean the
problem for the PGA was not that it was
Saudi and that not what it was anything
to do with morals the problem is
they had unlimited resources they
weren't going away it wasn't the AFL
wasn't the usfl wasn't the XFL they
could buy them and they did and we can
talk about that but the NFL relaxing
their rules on this kind of uh wealth
funds could happen I mean I think we're
seeing this Toe Hold I think the golf
deal this week is a first step
I think now there's maybe credibility is
too strong a word Dan but now there's
this feeling okay they're in golf they
host Qatar hosted the World Cup they're
in Formula One their own Newcastle
United it's not a stretch to see them
get in the core four American Sports
even the NFL well it takes me back to
when the Commissioners would all say in
unison no sports team will be in Vegas
yeah and and we see what's happening now
and there'll be an NBA franchise in
Vegas you already have the Raiders there
the Oakland A's looking to move there
but what sport do you see as maybe next
for this Saudi Investment Group to try
to purchase get involved with
yeah it's interesting I know you had uh
silver on yesterday he had those
comments but I do think it's that one
they have relaxed their rules to allow
for Sovereign wealth funds and Sovereign
wealth funds could include the public
investment Fund in Saudi Arabia it can't
anytime soon but yeah when we talk about
NBA franchises getting to three billion
dollars getting to four billion dollars
the Phoenix Suns Matt ishbia there's
only a Cadre of multi-billionaires out
there to do this let me tell you this
Dan the commanders Josh Harris of course
he owns the Sixers he owns the Devils
he's still you know they're still
vetting him and there's issues with all
these other I know a person in DC I'm
from there and a well-to-do guy and he
said I got a prospectus
they basically wanted 100 million for
you know good I could get good tickets I
mean what is he going to get out of 100
million and it's not a lot so I think at
some point they're going to look to
resources Beyond this and we can talk
about sports washing but this is
desensitizing this whole thing
what is next for live in PGA Tour and
and how much involvement will the Saudis
have as we move forward
you know I think this is the debate that
I talk about all the time in business of
sports it's the money versus the control
I think Jay Monahan did a deal where he
maintains a level of control as whatever
is going to be commissioner CEO having
people on his board
but they got the money
they meaning the Saudi public investment
fund were 700 billion dollars they are
the sole investor and they have a writer
first refusal over any other investor
and I don't think I or other people are
being hyperbolic when they say they
bought golf
and the money is going to eventually
have a lot of control
perception is Jamon hand retains control
they're still a PGA but there's a 2B
formed entity
owned by the Saudis
and that's reality from what we know
about the deal terms and I think that's
extraordinary extraordinary uh I think
their infiltration into golf in one Fell
Swoop is extraordinary
we're talking Andrew Brandt and uh he's
the host of business of sports podcast
what's Aaron Rodgers making with the
Jets
well this hasn't been worked out I mean
he's got basically 100 million over two
years we've heard that he's deferred the
bonus of 60 million to next year but we
haven't seen details of that the bottom
line is 101 million over the next two
years by the way the Packers offloaded
that for a player that was never going
to play for them again so good on them
but he'll make it the question is when
and how and to me that sort of opens up
the question will he play next year
because if he doesn't there's all that
guaranteed money but that's that's for
next year but I was bringing this up on
the show recently
the let's say the next
big salary like what what sport is going
to have that salary where you go like
show hey Otani it might be a 600 million
dollar contract and then he would be
maybe it's a 10-year 600 million that's
60 million a year
when are we going to Broach in what
sport somebody making a hundred million
dollars a year
well if they go to the Saudi League
okay
you know Lionel Messi turned down three
years 1.5 billion or something like that
uh to go to Miami but um you know you
see the creep let's talk about the sport
I talk about most football you see the
slow creep with the Jalen hurts at 51
and Lamar Jackson at 52 although there's
structural issues with those deals that
don't make them quote real in the later
years we'll see but yeah I mean I think
we're going to creep up to that 60
million Mark in football but football
teams have an ability to get out of
these contracts that other other players
don't I think you know when we see
Damian Lillard making 60 million in the
NBA it's real I mean we see future
future salaries out years for Russell
Westbrook and 50 something and out year
for you know even Carl towns is going to
have an out year at 60 million dollars
in a couple years so you see where
that's going when you only have this
limited number of players making that
could you see Victor one by Yama yeah if
he lives up to the billing
he's 18. by the time you know he's 30.
could he be making a hundred million
dollars a year I think he could I think
we could have a 300 million cap
in the NBA for 15 players
so I think that could happen now we're
you know where to cap
an apron of 180 million dollars for 15
players and teams are going above that
yeah so I think that could happen and
then you talk about Otani and baseball
you know what's striking to me in
baseball Dan is the length
I wanted to ask you about Kyler Murray
I've been critical of the Cardinals that
they jumped the gun and I was like you
know you don't you didn't need to but
they did and now they're stuck with this
but now you start to get the sense if
Arizona is going to be as bad as we
think they are they're going to have the
number one pick overall and you got
Caleb Williams there can how does
Arizona get out of that Kyler Murray
contract
well you know what I always say these
NFL contracts are really two years and
we'll see you know we'll see if we want
to keep you what's so ironic about Kyler
is he was drafted a year after they took
a number one pick as quarterback Josh
Rosen so it could happen again listen I
totally believe they jumped the gun we
saw a year ago all these sort of snarky
uh tweets from his agent and he was
playing for peanuts as a starter for
three years
they they count out to him and
um now they're going to deal with it
hopefully that he's going to live up to
that and get the next bump when they
bring in new Talent next year but this
looks like a rough year for that team
yeah but I don't think that he's going
to be healthy enough to put up those
numbers where you go yep he's our guy
and if I'm Arizona and I could you know
reset the clock with my quarterback no I
I they may have the top two picks in the
draft yeah I mean I think they'll have
some guaranteed money next year but it's
offset guarantee so if he goes to
another team that comes off their
financial bill but the way the NFL is
going yeah they move on from these
quarterbacks that don't hit it big early
you know look at the Jets of course uh I
know that you're following the gambling
in the NFL
um
are these players are they up to speed
on what they can and can't do and and if
they are are they just choosing to you
know be naive or ignorant
yeah I mean the Isaiah Rogers thing is
the latest it's hard to see him playing
again if they give a year for Calvin
Ridley you know what are they going to
do for a guy with repeated repeated
repeated gambling
listen this is gonna sound like I'm I'm
I'm defending these players I'm not
but it's in your face
FanDuel Caesars is the NFL sponsor I
mean they can't go anywhere without
media is I mean business supports
podcast sponsored by DraftKings let me
hold disclosure
I I can understand players with the
mixed message like wait a minute I can't
do that like I can't do that I can't do
it on my app
and I'm not defending it but the bottom
line is you're right the teams have to
do a better job of doing this you know
when when I was with the Packers we were
we were
uh called on the carpet by the NFL
because our players were in the media
saying you know they were going to give
our defensive backs where we can give
our defensive line some DVDs or or uh
gift certificates if they held Adrian
Peterson under 100 yards I mean we got
called on the carpet for that
and now you know gambling so it's the
biggest sea change in the World of
Sports in the last five years I mean
this was taboo the NFL fought this in
court for 10 years Tony Romo couldn't do
a fantasy football convention I remember
that and look where we are Vegas in your
face but yeah players can't it's very
simple and that will be hammered home in
these meetings great to talk to you
again Andrew thanks for joining us
always a pleasure Dan take care Andrew
Brandt making us smarter former Packers
executive and host of business of sports
let's take a break got a lot of phone
calls to get to